♪ ♪
>> Jesse: THE LIBERAL MEDIA
WASTING NO TIME TO POLITICIZE
HURRICANE EVEN USING THE
DANGEROUS STORM DO YOU PUSH
THEIR USUAL CLIMATE CHANGE
HYSTERIA.
>> THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT CLIENT
SCIENTIST HAS BEEN LOOKING ABOUT
FOR A LONG TIME.
>> HOW CONCERNED YOU ARE ABOUT
WHAT IS NEXT.
GIVEN CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> CLIMATE CHANGE MAKING STORMS
BIGGER AND MORE COSTLY.
>> WE HAVE IAN HITTING SO HARD
AND SO FAST ESPECIALLY IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER RECENT
STORMS.
IT RAISES THE QUESTION ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WHAT DEGREE
THAT IS FUELING ITS POWER
APPEARED TO OUR EARTH IS GETTING
WARMER AND THERE IS NO DOUBT IT
IS FEEDING THESE BEASTS.
>> WHERE IT COMES OUT AS THE
INTENSITY.
>> Jesse: BUT WATCH WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THEY COME
FACE-TO-FACE WITH AN ACTUAL
SCIENTIST.
>> CAN YOU TELL US WHAT THIS IS
AND WHAT EFFECT CLIMATE CHANGE
HAS ON THIS?
>> WE CAN COME BACK AND TALK
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AT A LATER
TIME, I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
HERE AND NOW.
>> WHAT AFFECT IS CLIMATE CHANGE
HAVE ON THIS PHENOMENON THAT IS
HAPPENING?
IT SEEMS THESE STORES ARE
INTENSIFYING, THAT IS THE
QUESTION.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU CAN LINK
CLIMATE CHANGE TO ANY ONE EVENT.
>> THIS AND I GREW UP THERE AND
THESE STORMS ARE INTENSIFYING,
SOMETHING IS CAUSING THEM TO
INTENSIFY.
>> Jesse: DON LEMON GREW UP
THERE, SO HE KNOWS ABOUT HOW
FEROCIOUS THESE THINGS CAN
BECOME A GREG.
>> Greg: THAT IS SCIENCE.
REMEMBER THAT TIME HE WONDERED
IF A MISSING JET PLANE WENT INTO
A BLACK HOLE?
THAT WAS ALL TIME, 100% LEMON.
THE THEORY IS, LIKE, IF YOU
ALWAYS HAVE THE SAME ANSWER FOR
EVERYTHING, IT IS GLOBAL WARMING
AND CLIMATE CHANGE, YOU MIGHT BE
A ROBOT, RIGHT?
HOW WEIRD IT IS YOU ARE TRAPPED
IN A SINGLE FILTER FOR
EVERYTHING AND IT IS A REFLEX
THOUGHT AND YOU NEVER STOP TO
THINK, MAYBE THERE IS SOMETHING
ELSE.
YOU CAN GO WAY DOWN THE
RABBIT HOLE LOOKING AT THE CAUSE
AND EFFECT OF MAN-MADE CLIMATE
CHANGE, YOU WILL COME OUT NO
SMARTER, NO DUMBER, BECAUSE THEY
CONTRADICT EACH OTHER
CONSTANTLY.
DEATHS BY EXTREME WEATHER HAVE
DECLINED ALMOST OVER 90% OVER
THE LAST CENTURY.
LIKE I SAID IN THE FIRST BLOCK,
SO MANY HOUSES HAVE BEEN BUILT
AND THEY HAVE BEEN BUILT FURTHER
AND FURTHER OUT, YET WE SEE A
DECLINE IN DEATHS, SO THAT IS
INTERESTING.
I THINK THE SCIENCE, THEY ARE
NOT TALKING THE SCIENCE.
THEY ARE JUST IN THAT KIND OF
REFLEX MODE WHICH HAPPENS WHEN
YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
SAME THING IN THE SAME WAY FOR
40 YEARS.
IT JUST COMES OUT OF YOUR MOUTH
AND YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW -- YOU
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHY YOU ARE
SAYING IT FEARFUL HE JUST FEELS
THAT IT IS RIGHT.
>> Jesse: DANA, FOR THE
SEMINOLE INDIANS TRACKING
HURRICANE SPEEDS BEFORE THE
WHITE MAN ARRIVED?
>> Dana: NO.
>> Jesse: WAS THE WHITE MAN
EVEN TRACKING HURRICANE SPEEDS
IN FLORIDA 100 YEARS AGO?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Dana: THAT IS AN
INTERESTING THING.
DON LEMON, HE GREW UP THERE, HE
SAYS HE GREW UP THERE.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE YOU AN EXPERT,
OF COURSE, BUT YOU CAN HAVE A
FEELING FOR A PLACE AND A DESIRE
FOR PEOPLE TO BE WELL, BUT IT
DOES MISSES THE POINT THAT THEY
HAVE ADDED MILLIONS OF HOMES AND
PEOPLE AND THE SAME WILL BE TRUE
WHEN WE SEE MORE WILDFIRES THIS
FALL, AS WE USUALLY SEE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT IS REALLY DRY
OUT WEST.
EVERYONE IS LIKE, WELL, THAT IS
GLOBAL WARMING, AS WELL.
ACTUALLY, MORE PEOPLE ARE LIVING
IN THE WILD URBAN INTERFACE,
THAT IS WHY IT IS CALLED --
PEOPLE ARE LIVING ALONG THE
COASTLINE.
ONE GREAT THING ABOUT THIS IS A
LOT OF PEOPLE DID OBEY THE
EVACUATION ORDERS AND FLORIDA IS
REALLY WELL VERSED IN
COORDINATION WITH NOT JUST THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT AMONGST
EACH OTHER.
ALL OF THESE COUNTIES ARE
TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY ARE GREAT
FRIENDS AND THEY KNOW EACH OTHER
VERY WELL, SO THEY CAN
COMMUNICATE.
THE THING THAT KILLED ME IS IT'S
THE DEMOCRATS THAT ARE VERY,
VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE LOSS OF
TRUST IN EXPERTS.
AND HERE YOU HAVE A GUY FROM
NOAA, ANSWERING DON LEMON
SPECIFICALLY AND BRAVELY, I
WOULD SAY, BECAUSE THE PEER
PRESSURE MUST BE INTENSE, AND
THEY ARE DISMISSING HIM.
THAT IS NOT WHAT I WANTED TO
HEAR.
>> Jesse: WE DON'T LIKE THOSE
EXPERTS.
IF JOE BIDEN HAD SPENT ALL THIS
MONEY ON CLIMATE CHANGE A FEW
YEARS AGO, WHAT IT MAY BE HAVE
BEEN A CAT 1?
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
>> Jesse: THAT'S THE THEORY.
>> Harold: I THINK THE CHIEF
FROM THE NOAA HAD IT RIGHT.
WE CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT MAN'S
BEHAVIORS HAVE DONE TO THE
CLIMATE, BUT THIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO DO THAT.
THIS IS THE TIME TO LOVE THY
NEIGHBOR AND FIGURE OUT WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN ENCOURAGE CITIZENS
TO FOLLOW LOCAL AUTHORITIES AREL
STATE AND FEDERAL AUTHORITIES
TO WORK TOGETHER.
PLENTY OF TIME TO DEBATE CLIMATE
CHANGE, THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO
DO IT.
WE CAN HAVE A ROBUST DEBATE LIKE
WE DO AROUND THIS TABLE, BUT IT
IS SILLY TO INJECT AT A TIME
WHEN PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING FOR
THEIR LIVES, EVEN TONIGHT, THE
THING HAS ESCALATED TO A
CATEGORY 1 AND PEOPLE AND CUT
CHARLESTON, SOUTH CAROLINA, AND
NORTH CAROLINA ARE HAVING TO
FACE THIS AND HERE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO DO IT
AND I HOPE EVERYONE SHOW SOME
RESTRAINT.
>> Jesse: JUDGE, IF FLORIDIANS
HAD USED SOLAR PANELS --
>> Jeanine: WOULD NOT HAVE --
>> Jesse: HOW WOULD THEY TURN
THE POWER BACK ON?
>> Harold: IT WOULDN'T HAVE
MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
I HAVE BEEN THROUGH A HURRICANE
AND LOST OUR HOUSE SO I KNOW
LIKE DON LEMON KNOWS, IT ONE
TIME MAYBE DMAN BIT OF
DIFFERENCE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT ARE SO FOCUSED ON POLITICS,
POWER, AND WINNING, THAT AT
EVERY TURN, EVERY OPPORTUNITY,
THEY BRING POLITICS IN.
WHEN AMY KLOBUCHAR SAYS NOW, NOW
THAT WE HAVE SEEN THIS, NOW WE
KNOW THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO WIN
IN THE MIDTERM, THAT DON LEMON
AND JOY BEHAR AT ALL THE REST OF
THEM, BIDEN NOW THREATENING THE
OIL COMPANIES, SAYING YOU BETTER
NOT GET THOSE GAS PRICES UP.
I MEAN, THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
EMPATHIZE, TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU LOSE EVERYTHING
THAT IS FAMILIAR TO YOU, WHEN
YOU LOSE YOUR HOUSE AND HAVE
NOWHERE TO GO, PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT YOU LIKE, YOU KNOW,
WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO SLEEP?
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO SLEEP AT MY
HOUSE ANYMORE.
AND THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
AND RED CROSS COME IN WITH A CUP
OF COFFEE YOU ALMOST WANT TO GET
ON YOUR KNEES AND THANK THEM.
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE AT THE BOTTOM
OF YOUR LIFE IN TERMS OF, WHAT
AM I GOING TO DO, WHAT AM I
GOING TO GO?
AND WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO SEE,
WHAT THE LEFT IS GOING TO SEE
ABOUT AMERICA IS HOW WE COME
TOGETHER, HOW FROM ALL OVER THIS
COUNTRY, WE'D COME TOGETHER, WE
TAKE CARE OF EACH OTHER, WE ARE
GENEROUS, WE ARE COMPASSIONATE,
AND WHILE THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE DEMS TRIED TO, YOU KNOW,
THEY HAVE THIS INCENDIARY, YOU
ARE SEMIFASCIST OR SEMINAZI
WHATEVER THE HELL 74 MILLIONS
AMERICANS ARE, THEY ARE GOING TO
SEE WE LOVE EACH OTHER AND TAKE
CARE OF EACH OTHER AND THIS IS
THE TIME TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE OUT OF PAIN AND YOU
CAN DO YOUR POLITICKING LATER.
>> Jesse: JUST LIKE WE CAME
TOGETHER AFTER THE STORM HIT
TEXAS AND THEN SANDY AND THIS
ONE DOWN IN FLORIDA.